[RUSTLING]
JAMES MCLURKIN: All right.
[RUSTLING AND TAPPING]
[SPINNING]
[TEAR]
[TAP]
[SIGH]
[CLICK]
How tall is the Space Needle?
DEVICE: The Space
Needle is 605 feet tall.
JAMES MCLURKIN: What
does a train sound like?
DEVICE: This is a train.
[TRAIN WHISTLE]
[CHUGGING]
So the goal of AIY Projects is
to get a AI out to everybody,
being able to build
a tool that takes
really powerful, sophisticated
artificial intelligence
and reduces it down to
literally a cardboard box.
The possibilities are limitless.
[BEEPING]
You do need to add a
little bit of software
in order to tailor it
to do exactly what you
want to do, to look for the
words that you want to find.
After that, you
need to connect it
to what you want to control--
train, fast--
[TRAIN WHIRRING]
--motors or light or
turbos or anything else
that you can control with
an electrical signal.
[TRAIN WHIRRING]
It literally is
just that simple.
If you can plug wires
into a circuit board,
then you can connect a
motor to the voice kit.
Train, stop.
[TRAIN WHIRRING]
[WHIRRING STOPS]
There we go.
So we built this kit for
makers, for people like you
who love building stuff,
who love tinkering,
who love taking things apart,
who love making things better.
So I want to know what the users
are going to build and to see
where they take it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]